hey guys so I just wanted to make a
quick video to show a really nice
resource in the chess and this would be
more suitable for newer newer players
who are perhaps just learning the rules
trying to understand the basics so if
there's anyone watching who's like very
new to chess or if you know someone who
is looking to learn chess but not sure
how to learn I can highly recommend
checking out this resource on me chess
and the way to access it you just go to
learn and then chess basics you can also
go to vGHS org slash learn I can leave a
link in the video description
but essentially you'll reach this page
with a bunch of different exercises
covering how each piece moves covering
some very fundamental themes between
capturing and mating and checking and
then some some other types of exercises
too so what I thought I'd do is just
walk through some of these and show how
fun and interactive they are and then
then I would recommend anyone who who
who might find these useful to go and
and and attempt these at your own pace
now I should note that it keeps track of
your progress
before starting the recording I had to
reset my progress because I had done
these before with some younger students
but if you complete all the exercises
and you'll get a hundred percent so I'm
going to start with the rook and okay we
have some nice page here say let's go
and this is gonna be very easy so I'll
just collect the Stars maybe it will get
harder but I really enjoy using this
with kids because it's very interactive
I think visually it's it's interesting
okay this is complicated want to take
everything efficiently
okay there we go this time there's two
rooks and the sounds are so rewarding
okay I have to be a bit careful here
there we go okay so that was uh that was
a rook get some nice sound effect I'm
not sure how annoying that will be on
the video recording but but too bad so
we'll go back to the menu we could move
on to the bishop let's go back let's try
a difference for them exercise can work
on the other pieces of course let's do
let's do protection see how this is I've
done this a while ago but um it has been
some time okay so the bishop is
attacking the rook and essentially we
have to move to the only safe Square
[Music]
okay we can move the knight to a few
different squares here this time we have
to protect the knight with a rook
[Music]
the bishop at the pond
this time we blocked the bishop with a
pawn which is defended by the Knights so
I'm sure for many people watching this
is just ridiculously easy but the whole
point is is to have a resource for
players who might not not be that well
equipped with chess basics this time
what's going on I could move the Knight
to c4 or I could move the bishop there's
two of his two darks red bishops
really nice c4 I think there's a few
solutions to this I could also play rook
be one let me see for how the Queen
attacking everything
rook out three or Knight d4 play Knight
d4 okay that was satisfying we'll do one
more back to menu
I'm kind of curious what does stalemate
let's try it
obviously I know what stalemate is I'm
just curious what the exercises will be
okay let's go uh uh
so basically we're gonna stalemate the
King which normally in a game you don't
tell me it's but okay next
this is still me right that's cool I
like the arrows there next
still needs this is stalemate
assume we have to take the rook and
that's still me nice okay
so yeah I'm not gonna do all of these
I've already completed 17 percent so and
then of course at the towards the end of
this you have other other different
types of features on me chess another
thing which I'll I guess I'll show which
is more suitable for players who already
understand the rules of chess who might
want something more challenging you also
have a practice I think this is yeah you
have practice with different types of
exercises relating to mates and tactics
and end games and it's the same sort of
interface with kind of a series of
different exercises so I don't think
I'll go through these because the whole
point is so is for our players to work
through at their own pace